los estadounidenses se acercan a tener
una segunda vacuna un panel de expertos
se recomendó la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos autorizar el
uso de emergencia del fármaco de moderna
y la evidencia que se ha estudiado en
gran detalle sobre esta vacuna supera
con creces cualquier problema que
hayamos visto
creo que realmente nos ayuda a poder
poner la pandemia detrás realmente
avanzar y finalmente brindar una forma
segura y efectiva de lograr la inmunidad
colectiva
donde según las autoridades si se
aprueba el uso de la vacuna de moderna
la próxima semana se podrían sumar 79
millones de dosis adicionales a la
campaña iniciada en eeuu con el fármaco
de facer y variante que estas dos
inmunizaciones son las más avanzadas en
la carrera por vencer al cob y 19 y
comparten la tecnología a rn mensajero
que enseña de las células cómo producir
una proteína a la que reacciona el
sistema inmunitario ambas mostraron una
eficacia similar pero la vacuna de
moderna tiene una ventaja su
conservación a una temperatura similar a
la de los refrigeradores normales puede
facilitar su distribución por otro lado
las reacciones negativas en los
trabajadores de la salud de un hospital
de alaska tras recibir la vacuna de
facer y bayonne tec alimentaron las
dudas sobre su seguridad pero los
médicos defienden su calidad
y el riesgo relativo de tener una
reacción a la vacuna es extremadamente
bajo por lo que sabemos y quizás haya
alguno pero el riesgo de tener kobe ni
un cuadro severo es mucho mayor
con la esperanza en las vacunas eeuu
busca comenzar a dejar atrás la pandemia
que lo tiene como el país más afectado
del mundo